Brad tell us about the first few days of
working on the idea and the screenplay
for Frank the bastard yeah well i think
the the dawn of the story came to me
when I went up to Washington County
Maine for the first time I mean I grew
up in New England all different parts of
New England but Washington County Maine
was the wild wild East it's a really
primal kind of landscape and I was up
there teaching a sixth-grade class of
past makati Indians a filmmaking
workshop I brought a bunch of actors and
filmmakers up to work one-on-one with
the kids and they were all making their
loan movies and I was surrounded by this
crazy world with the Vietnam veterans
you know like the first time I was
driving into the town I was lost it was
foggy at night it was like claire and i
sold arriving and i pulled in porch of
the house and I see this old woman
looking down to the fog and I go excuse
me I'm looking for Lubec Maine and she
goes Evie from here ye be from away like
in that kind of wild it's a it's it's
not even Middle English it so it's a
variant of Old English that is still
spoken in part parts of Washington
County it's it's really something else
up there with the Pentecostal churches
and the there you know the Cyrus gas is
based on probably main greatest sort of
underclass criminal figure who ran all
sorts of different scams up there real
estate and you know toxic waste disposal
in you know so a lot of the characters
in the story are based on real-life
figures that I researched when I was up
there but i think you know there was
that world that i fell into at the same
time i think in my internal world i was
going through something of a midlife
crisis in terms of trying to come to
terms with things that had happened to
me when i was young coming of age during
the 60s you know I come from a somewhat
fractured and dysfunctional family full
of a lot of you know addiction and
mental illness like divorces and crazy
stuff but I'd always been sort of buoyed
by this
60s was a great coming of age during
that muse the music and as a young man
coming in New York and the theater and
um I you know I felt wow there's there's
hope and salvation in the arts and I and
storytelling in particular with drew me
and I grew up you know reading a lot of
literature and a lot of you know
old-time you know it since I considered
all time now as you know fiction I love
Southern gothic fiction I loved you know
Russian novels I loved you know where
deep dense storytelling was very
character-driven and very like something
that I had felt had gone out of movie
making and you know when I first decided
to become a filmmaker it was sort of
when I for me to let go of wanting to
become a fiction writer which is what I
initially wanted to do when I was really
young and gravitate toward movies was it
I right at that particular point in my
life I watched movies like The Godfather
and Chinatown you know that early 70s
stuff was just like mind-bending terms
of like wow these are the new novelists
these are the new storytellers are able
to use to scream as a way to get that
kind of incredible story density that
speaks to the modern age and even though
they're about old you know both those
films are about looking back on
historical periods they just and I was
very encouraged by you know the
possibility of being able to do that and
I can't like they're like a lot of my
life it became a rudder steady
disappointment and why I felt at the
time that I decided to make Frank the
bastard that indie filmmaking had sort
of first of all given up the you know
terms of trying to tell the big stories
the epic stories they relinquish that to
Hollywood and that Indian films were
sort of steadily shrinking and you know
this is sort of a dawn of like
mumblecore and and and stuff we're like
I was just like I just have no I don't
think that's as a storyteller what I'm
good at and what I want to do so I'll
take this one shot at telling you know a
very indie movie but make it feel like
it has an epic scale in terms of you
know characters you know that the cat's
the size of the cast the character
the scope of the time you know past and
present or all you know heavily explored
and and also being a journey film kind
of an epic journey for her Claire
descending really when she when you
first see her she's at the top of the
wooden Manhattan and that she literally
plummets into this world and I wanted to
get those themes and those storytelling
tropes all into this small relatively
low-budget indie film so it was a big
challenge why well Brad I understand
from your bio that you may be still are
or were a script doctor yep so from the
the mindset of a script doctor how did
you start the screenplay for Frank the
bastard like what were your beginning
stages I realize you had a lot of things
you wanted to put into a story and very
rich right you know I know you reference
Stephen King in the movie and the diss
fiction sort of that place right how
almost untouched by time it seemed but
but in terms of the actual structure and
how you started it what would you
remember the first day you actually said
none gonna write this story or how did
it well you know like I said I think it
started with finding that location and
going wow this is an opportunity like in
the way that think when John Ford first
stumbled onto Monument Valley he was
like oh wow I could tell a lot of
stories here this place just screams out
a certain type of narrative and I felt
that way about Washington County i also
had at the time a relative of mine who
was going through a bout of mental
illness schizophrenia and bipolar
disorder and so I was immersed in that I
saw a lot of you know he you know things
from my own family history that came out
in I worked on the screenplay a long
time I really developed it like it was a
novel almost it started with a lot more
story i just kept distilling it down
which is why it feels like it has a
certain density as you know as a friend
of mine says in the era of wine coolers
you've created a single malt whiskey
it's like you are like oh my god it's so
intense and so that distillation process
took a long time
yeah and it was also a bit of a stretch
for me to write a movie about a woman
protagonist I was I think at that point
in my life I was letting go of being a
young male and I was more in touch with
you know I was getting ready to start a
family and I needed to and you know
fittingly I had a daughter that's my one
child as a woman now young woman I I
felt a need to bridge the gap between
the very I was probably a fairly
masculine type of young man and kind of
obtuse in the way that that implies as
you might know being a woman and so it
was really great for me to explore you
know a character who starts off you not
only she a woman but she's also very
vulnerable and kind of damaged and the
pan I think that's you know I think that
was a part of myself that I needed to
bring out my own damage self which I
think up to that point my life I wasn't
comfortable with that so it was nice to
find a protagonist who could be that for
me um well and you do reference Stephen
King and I know I in his book on writing
he talks about writing a script and then
leaving it in a drawer for a little bit
yeah so for yourself as a script doctor
or former script doctor are you able to
quote leave it in a drawer for a little
bit and then come back and sharing it
from that critical mindset or yeah close
to the material no no I was able to do
that you know there was just enough
distance in this story and I did it a
number of times I think I did seven or
eight drafts of the screenplay over a
four-year period so I I definitely let
it sit and let it you know just like old
whiskey like I got better I think or it
certainly got more intense it's like
absolutely yeah mm-hmm switching gears a
little bit where did you go for
financing for Frank the bastard i mean
and i know it had a different title if a
furry it was well the original title was
actually Frank the best oh it was yeah
yeah we I was talked into a changing the
title by my producers rep who felt like
the movie was so intense that it didn't
need a super intense title
and also that there was a certain would
people understand there's a certain
irony about the title in that the film
is basically Claire's story and that
Frank the bastard is not only a spin on
you know the Gothic romance novels that
her friend is sold is that's her
portrayed but that that Frank the
bastard is also somewhat of a you know
as a reference they're using the word
Francoeur truth frankness truth
truthfulness being a mixture of things
not being a simple not there not being a
single path in life and not and I think
he just felt that that was way way too
literary and people wouldn't get that
and we should give give the film a very
you know accessible title in east of a
katie is a region in maine and so i went
with that initially and then you know
thank God enough people said to me are
you crazy that title was great you got
to keep it you know so it came back by
popular demand but then so the financing
you how did you secure financing for the
film you had the screenplay you know
location yeah you know and we had also
massachusetts film tax credit which was
huge you know at that point it was
thirty-five percent i mean it was really
low there's just no way we could have
shot that film in maine you know which
had no film stock trends which is why we
didn't it's that everything you see in
the movie was shot in on the coast of
Massachusetts oh yeah yeah so we were
able to secure financing by you know uh
with the film tax credit I i I'd because
I had been working on the film for so
long you know it was my second film but
my first film was extremely low budget
and it actually made me some money
miraculously enough and I you know I had
established enough credibility with a
group of investors mostly in New York
and in the banking world and you know it
took a long time to raise the money it
was a sort of an endless and very
frustrating series of thing but I didn't
make anything else me that's why I took
me so long to make a second film is that
I just I put all my eggs in one basket
so to speak and and
yeah I mean I learned first of all
patients cuz it's it's the hardest thing
in the world when you know you're you've
been taken on up a career in an art form
that does take so long I mean and and so
many things are out of your control in
terms of you know a painter has a canvas
and a brush and a writer has a pen and a
paper and computer now but you know
filmmakers are completely at the mercy
of a huge you know which you know I both
love and hate I love working with people
and you know and I some background in
theater so I was prepared a little bit
for filmmaking by working in a lot in
theatre which is is this similar as a
microcosm of film where you definitely
need a group and you need a network of
other creative people too but you know
it's a lot easier make a play that it is
to make a movie and in terms of just the
logistics of it so that prepared me but
and you know I guess I learned I'd
rather do you know one thing really true
to my ambition and trying to it as well
as I can rather than do like I never i
could have directed a couple of
commercials and during that period i was
offered other things that felt like
would have been fine you know career
moves and but i didn't I stuck with you
know this thing through hell and high
water and which you know which is what
it took because this film was so hard to
make you know in terms of its a for an
indie film has a fairly epic scale of
storytelling and production and so yeah
that's also taught me focus let's stay
focused over a long period of time that
was that was hard but yeah so will you
had your first film's the undeserved
okay and that was through IFC yeah and
then did sort of change your mindset
where you say you know I'm not just a
writer director I'm not just a filmmaker
and
an artist so to speak but I'm also a
small business owner did you ever think
in that yeah you have to I mean I kept
trying to keep my eye on the problem is
for filmmakers it is just you know it's
like being a musician back in in the 80s
you know when the bottom dropped out and
the whole landscape changed that had
nothing to do with individual art or
even business savvy it's just that the
model fell apart the business model fell
apart and that's what's happened to
indie filmmakers I mean when I moved to
San Francisco the first week I was there
Oh Steven Soderbergh's going to give a
speech to enter San Francisco Film
Center I'll go down there he got up in
front of 600 people and said I'm out of
here I can't do this anymore the whole
thing is you know and I remember the
conviction that he said you know it
whatever period of time and in some ways
he was interesting figure because I
think he ushered in the kind of the
great Sun Rise of independent film
production I remember first seeing Sex
Lies and videotape and going wow like
this is a really interesting you know
thing that's happening in filmmaking
where one guy a very singular vision
very it is innocent cratic film could
reach this mass of audience because it
was just so specifically good and
character driven and like just and it
you know it turned out to be a little
bit of a red herring I think they're
there was you know many independent
films that came out after that that were
great but that there might be a viable
way to make independent films in this
country that are going to reach an
audience like that and and and for him
to get up and say I'm done I can't do
this anymore was like shocking to me and
and and not shocking really but it was
sort of like oh no everything that I'm
feeling about the independent film world
is true that the daunting difficulty of
it all and the fact that it's you know
like if you're you know you were a
musician in the 80s and you'd been
making your you know you're living off
of selling CDs and you better figure out
a new plan immediately yeah that's what
it you know so I the film itself is
something of a throwback in terms of the
style and you know
and and I think the genre itself i don't
i don't think big indie that's another
thing i was like maybe this is the last
chance to make a really big a true big
indie film i I had the capability of
doing and I thought I had this story I
had the setting i had you know i'll just
take this one last crack and you know
and see what happens so so in that way
you know there wasn't it you know i
don't think it was the savviest business
move but i think that there was unique
reasons to try and make this film yeah
when you're writing conflict because i
know there's many scenes in the film
whether it's intense conflict are you
writing sort of an outline a structure
for it and then once you get with the
actors you give them more room to put
more fire into those scenes or are you
writing the intensity of the anger in
the screenplay well i think with this
screenplay you know because it had been
you know developed you know it was I
thought extremely already so intense and
very different working on this
screenplay than working on the
undeserved you know my first film which
was you know very much a Mike Lee
inspired when i started making that
movie i did not have a screenplay we I
dropped a bunch of actors into a small
town in Vermont and the town became the
blank canvas and we developed that story
through improvisation and actors running
around the town figuring out who was who
and it was just a really interesting
process where and my background had been
in assists a screenwriter again not a
set not the savviest business decisions
well in terms of like why was i I was
going against maybe my strength in my my
training but I felt something very vital
about that for that particular film and
doing it that way and i still think
Michael E is you know in terms of guys
who you know greatest living indie
filmmaker I I put him up there against
anyone and but this film I had the
screenplay and I didn't have a lot of
time you know to work with the actors in
that way thank God I had actors who were
very script savvy and didn't really need
a lot of prompting you don't have to
tell william sadler where the conflict
in a scene is
and uh you know and people like Chris
Sarandon you know they're just so such a
literary sensibility anyway he was
getting I mean he was helping me with
other characters not just his own
character ok yeah that there was a lot
of nice and rachel miner again same
thing just a deep insight into the of
the nuances of the script so we didn't
you know not only we did not have the
time but I even if I had I don't know if
I would have said much more than I had
to say during production yeah how close
were you to actually not making this
film yeah real close a couple there's a
couple of thought you know there was a
point two years before when we were
going to go up and shoot it and we had
some most of the financing in place but
you know Massachusetts had a smaller
film tax credit and we just we felt too
stretched thin and I wasn't 100% sure
that I could pull it off you know so I
again what I learned was patience and
and just when to make your move but yeah
it was it was a fraught journey for sure
it's like like Claire's tourney is like
you know as a twit was the quote by
Nietzsche twisted is the path to
eternity it's like very true yeah or the
one I like to is copla I think anything
that you build with love invites chaos
yeah something to that's a good yeah
tips to other filmmakers on keeping and
communication with their finance ears
but the people that are I'm sure most of
those people are very on point very
specific you know with things and and
I'm sure communication is probably the
number one thing but anything that
you've learned along the way you said
you've dealt with all these people most
of them were in the banking sector yeah
you know which is like you're constantly
talking to people who don't quite know
what you're talking about and you don't
know what they're talking about you know
in there when they're telling you it
like yeah there's there's always that uh
you know I again I would say patience
and and and also I think ultimately what
it comes down to when you're talking to
investors they know that it's a
crapshoot
they know that it's ridiculously I think
you know what people respond to even in
the business world more intensely than
making money or making something
successful is that they they respond to
authenticity they respond to something
that they feel is coming from a very
deep place in someone and I think that I
was always able to convey that that
there was a certain you know this story
was coming out of me in a profound way
it was a story I very much needed to
tell and I think at the end of the day
they sense that or most of them did
because there are people who dropped out
who are like yeah too crazy this whole
adventure seems like you know for sure I
you know you run into you know for every
some for every person that you're able
to to convince and to preach there's
someone who's like that they it's too
daunting it stick you know that's the
the gap between the business world and
the artistic world the artistic world is
often yeah it's not just it's chaos and
it's it's turmoil and it's it's an
interior T it's it's it's about you know
what was things that are going on the
inside which are often very hard to
articulate and and also to get people to
understand fact the bastard is slick
it's it's unique because it's it's such
a leap into this other world and to take
a Wall Street banker on that journey it
was like you know challenge would you
say you approach many things in life and
forgive me if I'm getting too personal
but because you mentioned that you know
things had been sort of a a winding
journey and you dealt with certain
things in your life that maybe that's
just just a product you've become a
product of that you are it's very
important to you sure make sure that you
have the right reasons driving you and
not just yeah yeah sure you know I've
always asked myself that question is is
something that's just is it specific to
me as a certain I mean I I once referred
to my brother and I as children of chaos
that that was the children of the
the flower children began to children of
chaos you know in terms of we came out
of that you know exciting tumultuous you
know that I yes I all my distant
memories of the 1960s or just like I
just could not believe that and you know
what was seeing Jimi Hendrix it'll
perform when I was nine years old it was
like crazy it was like I was like these
are God's these this is not just
personal God's rock stars this is a new
type of energy coming into the universe
and I was like you know I don't know how
many people can relate to that I mean I
can or the disappointment of having that
not really come too much that very soon
after the 60s Richard Nixon would get
elected and then Ron Reagan would come
along and then like you know if you're
you know if you're dreaming be prepared
to be crushed now that that may be part
of my my personal experience but I I
don't think I'm alone in that I think
that's a very human thing for to dream
and to hope for wholeness and and you
know for a world a fallen world to be
restored is I think a very you know it's
biblical it's you know it's it's in a
lot of religions and so but yeah I I can
never really fully answer that question
but I try all the time sure well
everyone can probably think of all the
negatives are coming from chaos but what
are the positives are coming from it
because I'm sure there's many things
that we wouldn't think of yeah i mean
i'd like for me is that I find that I
can go anywhere in the world I mean I'm
making a film now down in the city of
san pedro sula honduras which is
currently probably the most chaotic spot
on the planets the murder capital of the
world it's like a place in total free
fall and i can go into it city like
that'd feel pretty comfortable and
dialed in and reaching out to a
population it's a film about the only
girls orphanage in Honduras and it's
about them trying to learn how to write
poetry and it was like I just fell right
in it was like instantly connected to
and i know i think the way that the
world is going right now I being
something of a chaos manager is a good
is a good life skill
I think the thing that I try and not do
is succumb to a certain kind of
emotional that that there was certain
things that are particular to my sadness
or my pain or my trauma that really
specifically mind and that to somehow be
able to have that and to feel you know
always to make that part of not trying
to hide that or bury that because I
think it's a very common tendency but to
balance it with what's going on in the
world is it's it's that ongoing struggle
but I think it is a skill i think it is
something that I'm pretty good at and
hopefully we'll find ways to use it
because it's it's you know it's
something of a you know it's not like
I'm a a great entertainer you know I
don't have you know I'm drawn to certain
pockets of the world that most people
might shy away from and I don't
necessarily think that's always you know
a great thing but it has its uses I'll
say that